la ville de huy a été violemment touchés
par les orages mardi 22 juin dès 9h30 la
commune a été inondé les commerces et
habitations ont été impactés on essaie
de voir en fait soit puisque la même ça
commence à monter sur le salon en ce
sens on va y aller chez les amis ou chez
de la famille ou sinon on va voir c'est
ça c'est compliqué justement on va voir
comment ça va se faire avec la
protection civile mais on va s'organiser
avec comme ça une trentaine d'habitants
a été mis au sec et hébergés au total
ces 300 foyers qui sont coupés
d'électricité
donc aujourd'hui on a quasiment tous les
quartiers de la ville qui ont été
touchés donc on a plusieurs centaines de
personnes et plusieurs dizaines de
badauds missiles qui ont été touchés on
a énormément de commerces du
centre-ville qui ont été impactés on a
plusieurs commerces quand 55 cm d'eau là
dans la différentes parties de la ville
donc là ça a été assez massif
la présidente du conseil régional est
candidate à sa réélection valérie
pécresse s'est rendue sur place hier en
fin d'après midi les bénévoles de la
protection civile sont mobilisés à la
demande de la région pour venir en aide
notamment aux habitants
nous avons aussi un autre partenariat
avec la croix rouge qui est en train de
monter un gymnase d'hébergement
d'urgence à la demande du maire et nous
allons faire venir des food truck pour
pouvoir servir des repas d'urgence qui
est l'adaptation de la ville au
dérèglement climatique
c'est une compétence aujourd'hui qui est
une compétence de l'état
et moi je pense qu'elle devrait
décentralisée à la région aucun blessé
n'est à déplorer le maire va également
demander de faire reconnaître cet
épisode orageux en état de catastrophe
naturelle